As we are approaching our 300th episode of the show, the 9.9 PI crew took a couple days to go on a retreat up the coast and listen to the audio that inspires us and talk about the future of the show. Because of all the time it took to plan and execute the retreat, we have one of our rare re-broadcasts this week, and I'm happy to revisit it, because this is a pivotal episode for 9.9% invisible and one of my personal favorites. It was a really ambitious story for Avery at the time and we knew it was gonna be important. So we commissioned an original score for the first time
随着我们迎来节目的第300期，9.9% Invisible 团队花了几几天时间到海岸边进行了一次闭关，聆听激发我们灵感的音频，并讨论节目的未来。由于策划和开展这次闭关需要大量时间，本周我们播出一期少见的重播节目，我很高兴能再次回顾它，因为这对 9.9% Invisible 来说是一期具有关键意义的节目，也是我个人最喜欢的节目之一。对当时的埃弗里（Avery）来说，这是一个雄心勃勃的故事，我们知道它会很重要。因此我们首次委托创作了原创配乐
from Sean Rial who later came on staff to be our full-time composer. If you haven't heard this episode, you're in for a real treat. And if you have, you should listen again because I think it gets better each time. Stay tuned to the end because we have a brand new interview with Sean that I conducted late last night on the Foggy California coast about the score for this episode and the process of composing music for nerds to talk over.
作者是肖恩·里亚尔（Sean Rial），他后来加入团队，成为我们的全职作曲家。如果你还没听过这期节目，那可有福了。如果你听过了，你应该再听一遍，因为我觉得每次听都会更好。请听到最后，因为我们在加州大雾弥漫的海岸深夜采访了肖恩，聊了聊这期节目的配乐以及为唠叨的怪咖们创作音乐的过程，这是一个全新的采访。
Here we go. This is 99% Invisible. I'm Roman Mars. All over New York City, there are semi-clothes or nude women, and they are so baked into architecture that we don't even see them. For example, when you enter the New York Public Library on the left hand side, there's a sculpture of a young woman leaning against a horse. On 59th and 5th, there's a statue of a woman holding a basket of fruit. On 107th Street in Broadway, there's a woman reclining on a bed.
我们开始吧。这里是 99% Invisible。我是罗曼·马尔斯（Roman Mars）。在整个纽约市，有许多半穿衣服或裸体的女性，她们如此完美地融入了建筑之中，以至于我们甚至都没注意到她们。例如，当你从左侧进入纽约公共图书馆时，会看到一位年轻女性靠在一匹马上的雕塑。在第五大道和第59街交汇处，有一尊女性手提一篮水果的雕塑。在百老汇与第107街交汇处，有一位女性斜躺在床上。
That's former New Yorker Avery Troubleman. At 100th and Riverside Drive, a stone woman sits in a chair with a child. And on the very top of the New York Municipal Building, there's a golden woman holding a crown. And these women are actually the same woman. Audrey Munson was the most famous artist model in the United States. Over 30 statues at the Met are made in her likeness and she adorns dozens of memorials and bridges and regal buildings all over New York City. She basically was the equivalent of a supermodel at the time.
那是前纽约客埃弗里·特鲁弗曼（Avery Truffleman）。在河滨大道（Riverside Drive）与第100街交汇处，一个石雕女性正带着一个孩子坐在一把椅子上。而在纽约市政厅的顶端，有一尊手持王冠的金色女性雕塑。而这些女性实际上都是同一个人。奥黛丽·芒森（Audrey Munson）曾是美国最著名的艺术家模特。大都会艺术博物馆里有30多尊以她的外貌为原型的雕像，纽约市各处的许多纪念碑、桥梁和宏伟建筑上也都有她的身影。她基本上相当于当时的超级名模。
This is Andrea Gyer, an artist herself, an author of Queen of the Artist Studios, the story of Audrey Munson. Everybody knew who she was, her picture was in the papers, and if one trusts legend, like all every boy had a crush on her, she was a very desired young woman. In her lifetime, she would go on to decorate buildings and memorials all over the United States, before becoming a movie star, and eventually getting embroiled in a sensational murder scandal. And although Audrey Munson's body has been immortalized in iron and marble, her name is mostly forgotten, but she was a prolific writer and penned a series of articles telling
这位说话的是安德烈·盖尔（Andrea Gyer），她本人也是一位艺术家，同时是《艺术家工作室的女王：奥黛丽·芒森的故事》一书的作者。每个人都知道她是谁，她的照片登在报纸上，如果传说可信的话，几乎每个男孩都暗恋过她，她是一个备受追捧的年轻女性。在她的一生中，她为全美各地的建筑和纪念碑装饰，后来成为了一名电影明星，最终卷入了一场轰动的谋杀丑闻。尽管奥黛丽·芒森的身体被钢铁和大理石永远铭记，但她的名字大多已被遗忘，不过她是一位多产的作家，曾撰写了一系列文章讲述
her life in her own words, sometimes an luthered person. Where is she now? This model who was so beautiful. What has been her reward? Is she happy and prosperous? Or is she sad and far-lorn? Her beauty gone, leaving only memories in the wake. Like so many supermodels that would come after her,
她用自己的话描述的生活，有时是一个被剥夺了声音的人。她现在在哪里？这个曾经如此美丽的模特。她的回报是什么？她过得快乐而繁荣吗？还是悲伤而孤独？她的美貌已逝，只留下回忆在身后。就像后来出现的许多超模一样，
Audrey Marie Munson was scouted on the streets of New York City in 1906. Audrey's mother and father were divorced, which was very unusual at the time, and her mother decided to get a fresh start in the big city. Audrey was 15, enrolled in music school, and one day. She was picked up on the street by a photographer when she walked around with her mother. This photographer gave Audrey his card
奥黛丽·玛丽·芒森（Audrey Marie Munson）于1906年在纽约市的街头被星探发掘。奥黛丽的父母离异了，这在当时非常罕见，她的母亲决定在大城市重新开始生活。奥黛丽当时15岁，在音乐学校注册就读，有一天，当她和母亲在街上散步时，被一位摄影师在街上搭讪了。这位摄影师给了奥黛丽他的名片
and asked if she would pose for some portraits. Her mom was invited too, so intentions were good. These photos were fully clothed affairs. Audrey, by chance, was picked up as a model and then in the studio, proved that she was somebody who was very good with the camera, very good in creating and generating poses. This photographer recommended that Audrey meet a friend of his, the famous sculptor, Isador Conte.
并问她愿不愿意拍一些肖像照。她的母亲也被邀请了，所以意图是好的。这些照片都是穿着衣服拍摄的。奥黛丽机缘巧合被选为模特，随后在工作室里证明了她非常擅长面对镜头，非常擅长摆出和创造姿势。这位摄影师建议奥黛丽去见他的一个朋友，著名雕塑家伊斯多尔·孔蒂（Isador Conti）。
At first Conte thought he didn't really need Audrey, but as Audrey herself later recalled, suddenly he rose from the table, walked about me, asked me to stand and walk, and then said that he thought he could use me. But, said Mr. Conti, you will have to pose in the altogether. Posing in the altogether meant posing naked. Audrey's mother consented. If they would have been wealthy people, I don't think her mother would have led her pose in the nude. From that encounter, the resulting sculpture was the three muses, three nude women with their arms around each other, all three, modeled after Audrey. For decades, the sculpture was in the lobby of the hotel aster.
起初孔蒂觉得他并不真的需要奥黛丽，但正如奥黛丽后来回忆的那样，突然他从桌旁站起来，围着我转了几圈，让我站起来走走，然后说他觉得他可以用我。但是，孔蒂先生说，你必须一丝不挂地摆姿势。“一丝不挂”意味着全裸摆姿势。奥黛丽的母亲同意了。如果他们是有钱人，我想她母亲是不会让她裸体摆姿势的。那次相遇诞生的雕塑就是《三美神》（The Three Graces），三个裸体女性互相搂着手臂，三个人都是以奥黛丽为原型创作的。几十年来，这座雕塑一直摆放在阿斯特酒店的大堂里。
Audrey called this statue, quote, a souvenir of my mother's consent. And this was the first of many sculptures that she would model for Isadora Conte. Audrey began to work for many other famous artists in New York. As her reputation grew, she was recommended from studio to studio and slowly, her likeness appeared, mostly naked or half naked, all over the city. In 1913, the New York sun dubbed her Miss Manhattan. But Audrey is not always recognizable in sculpture. Her figure is different in different artists' eyes.
奥黛丽称这座雕像为“我母亲同意的纪念品”。这是她为伊斯多尔·孔蒂当模特的许多雕塑中的第一个。奥黛丽开始为纽约许多其他著名艺术家工作。随着她的名气越来越大，她在各个工作室之间被推荐，慢慢地，她的形象——大多是全裸或半裸——出现在了整个城市的各个角落。1913年，纽约《太阳报》称她为“曼哈顿小姐”。但在雕塑中并不总能一眼认出奥黛丽。在不同的艺术家眼中，她的身材各不相同。
Sometimes she's live. Sometimes she's fuller. From sculpture to sculpture, there are no obvious giveaways that you're looking at Audrey's body. The clues are in her face. It's the expressions of the eyes and the mouth and the nose. Like once you know how she looks, you can see her everywhere.
有时她很苗条。有时她更丰满。从一座雕塑到另一座雕塑，并没有明显的线索表明你看到的是奥黛丽的身体。线索在她的脸上。那是眼睛、嘴巴和鼻子的神情。就像一旦你知道了她长什么样，你就会到处看到她。
It's really fascinating. I would like look at sculptures in the mat and be like, that looks like her and then research and be, yeah, be right, that was her. Before it was easy for artists to snap a reference picture, Audrey could pose in a way that could evoke a mood. She must have been a very empathetic person, she could really translate emotion fully into her body.
这真的很迷人。我会看着大都会艺术博物馆里的雕塑，心想，那看起来像她，然后去查证，结果发现，没错，那就是她。在艺术家们能够轻松抓拍参考照片之前，奥黛丽能够以一种能够唤起某种情绪的方式摆姿势。她一定是一个很有同理心的人，她能够将情感完全转化为她的身体语言。
Audrey can hold the same pose for hours, sometimes for an entire day. And she worked closely with the artists, learning their temperaments, familiarizing herself with their past work. She thought of herself as a collaborator, as she told the New York herald in 1915. Study? Yes indeed I do. Every model who is a real success must study the work of the persons she is with. Audrey's unique set of skills earned her a decent salary, about $35 a week, which today would be like $800 a week. She made enough to give a day's salary to the suffragist movement, which was in full
奥黛丽可以保持同一个姿势几个小时，有时甚至整整一天。她与艺术家们紧密合作，了解他们的脾气，熟悉他们过去的作品。她认为自己是一个合作者，正如她在1915年对纽约《先驱报》所说的那样：“学习？当然啦。每一个真正成功的模特都必须研究她合作对象的工作。”奥黛丽独特的一系列技能为她赢得了可观的薪水，大约每周35美元，这在今天相当于每周800美元。她赚的钱足够每天拿出一天的薪水捐给当时正搞得轰轰烈烈的
swing around her. Audrey was an independent, confident woman at a good time to be a sculpture model. Because the architecture that was in Vogue in the United States from the end of the 19th century through World War I was the Bozart style. And this style required a lot of sculptures and detailed ornamentation. It was a great time in many ways to be an artist. This is architectural historian Karen McNeil. Whether you an architect, a sculptor, a painter, a crafts person making lamps. You've seen Bowsart style architecture. Virtually all state capitals are in the style. That image of an authoritative building with columns and statues all around, maybe a big dome. That's Bozart's. The style is a cross between like
女性选举权运动。对于一个雕塑模特来说，奥黛丽是一个独立、自信的女性，生逢其时。因为从19世纪末到第一次世界大战期间，美国盛行的建筑风格是美术字风格（Bozart风格，即学院派/布杂艺术）。这种风格需要大量的雕塑和详细的装饰。从许多方面来看，对于艺术家来说，这是一个伟大的时代。这位是建筑历史学家卡伦·麦克尼尔（Karen McNeil）。无论你是建筑师、雕塑家、画家，还是制作灯具的工匠。你都见过美术字风格的建筑。几乎所有的州议会大厦都是这种风格。那种带有柱子和四周雕塑、可能还有一个大圆顶的威严建筑形象。那就是美术派。这种风格介于
stately Greek Parthenon and flowery French Versailles. So a Bozart building, it's a Greek temple, but then you do have the sculptures on it, you do have the Frieze work, you do have all of this ornamental detail that is integral to the building. An architecture and sculpture are really bound together in this movement. When you take the decorative elements off
庄严的希腊帕台农神庙和繁复的法国凡尔赛宫之间。所以一座美术派建筑，它是一座希腊神庙，但上面有雕塑，有浮雕，有所有这些建筑不可或缺的装饰细节。在这场运动中，建筑和雕塑真正结合在了一起。当你把装饰元素从
of a Baux-Arre building, it looks weird. The dimensions don't quite work anymore. But also, the sculptures are signs of the building's purpose. They're very overtly representational. Like in a private home, the statues are of domestic scenes or on a market there of harvest and eating for a government building, say San Francisco City Hall. It's all gonna tell us about this is the seat of government
美术派建筑上拿掉时，它看起来就很奇怪。尺寸不再那么协调了。而且，这些雕塑也是建筑用途的标志。它们具有非常公开的代表性。比如在私人住宅中，雕塑是家庭场景；或者在市场上，雕塑是丰收和饮食；对于政府建筑，比如旧金山市政厅。这一切都在告诉我们，这是加州的
in California so great and fabulous and but it's all gonna be allegorical. In a government building, you might find a statue of a woman holding an olive branch or the scales of justice representing the state, liberty, truth, you name it. Just women placed on this pedestal of virtue, morality, motherhood, nurturing, strength. Women decorated the seat of power.
政府所在地，宏伟而壮丽，但这一切都将是寓言式的。在政府大楼里，你可能会看到一个女性雕塑，手里拿着橄榄枝或正义的天平，代表着国家、自由、真理，应有尽有。女性被置于美德、道德、母亲、培育和力量的基座上。女性装点了权力宝座。
They didn't sit on it. Why's it gotta be a lady? Because women are pure. You know, a woman with a spear, she would only use that spear to really defend her kids. Right? So it has to be, it has to be female. And for several years, this pure,
她们却没有坐在上面。为什么非得是个女士呢？因为女性是纯洁的。你知道的，一个拿着长矛的女性，她只会用那根长矛来真正保护她的孩子。对吧？所以必须是，必须是女性。多年来，美国这种纯洁的、
uncorrupt symbol of virtue in the US was Audrey Munson. She was everywhere. At the world's fair in 1915 held in San Francisco, Audrey posed for three quarters of the statues on the premises. Her face and body appeared everywhere throughout the grounds. That's Erin Garcia of the California Historical Society. She curated an exhibit about the 1915 Panama Pacific Exposition in San Francisco, where Audrey
未受污染的美德象征就是奥黛丽·芒森。她无处不在。在1915年旧金山举办的世界博览会上，奥黛丽为会场上四分之三的雕像当了模特。她的脸庞和身躯出现在整个场地的各处。这位是加州历史学会的埃琳·加西亚（Erin Garcia）。她策划了一个关于1915年旧金山巴拿马太平洋万国博览会的展览，奥黛丽
Munson was dubbed the Exposition Girl. In the quarter four season, she was the seasons. She was at the base of the fountain of energy. She was rain. She was the priestess of culture at the Palace of Fine Arts. She posed for 91 figures meant to represent the stars. She was all over the place. At about 24 years old, Miss Manhattan had won the West, and there was a new form of art entering the scene. Cinema. The obvious next stop for Audrey Munson was Hollywood. And Hollywood was, unfortunately, the beginning of the end for Audrey Munson.
芒森在那里被称为“博览会女孩”。在四个季节的雕塑中，她就是四季。她是能量喷泉的基座。她是雨。她是美术宫的文化女祭司。她为旨在代表星星的91个人物当了模特。她无处不在。大约24岁时，曼哈顿小姐征服了西部，而一种新的艺术形式正在进入大众视野。电影。奥黛丽·芒森显而易见的下一站是好莱坞。而不幸的是，好莱坞也是奥黛丽·芒森走向没落的开始。
She is cast in a few films after the exposition, but in every case she is cast as a nude model, as an artist model and she appears nude. Audrey was actually the first leading woman in Hollywood to appear naked on film. And Audrey may have been a good model, but she honestly wasn't much of an actress. In a few of her films, she actually had an acting double, who would basically do everything except the naked posing. And the movies didn't end up really being worth it for her financially. She was paid very little.
博览会结束后，她参演了几部电影，但在每一部电影中，她都被饰演为裸体模特、艺术家模特，并且她都是裸体出镜。奥黛丽实际上是好莱坞第一位在电影中全裸出镜的女主角。奥黛丽可能是一个好模特，但老实说，她并不是一个好演员。在她的一些电影中，她实际上有一个演戏替身，基本上除了裸体摆姿势外，其他一切都由替身完成。对她而言，拍电影在经济上并不真的划算。她得到的报酬非常少。
And none of them seemed to have been critical successes. That might have been okay for her. Her career might have survived that. But then, unfortunately, she was involved in a murder scandal. Audrey and her mother had an apartment in New York. And their landlord, Dr. Wilkins, fell in love with Audrey. Her landlord apparently became obsessed with her and killed his wife so that he could be with Audrey. Being with Audrey was a one-sided delusion.
而且这些电影似乎都不是评论界大获成功的作品。这对她来说可能还算过得去。她的职业生涯可能还能挺过去。但随后，不幸的是，她卷入了一场谋杀丑闻。奥黛丽和她的母亲在纽约有一间公寓。他们的房东威尔金斯医生（Dr. Wilkins）爱上了奥黛丽。她的房东显然对她产生了痴迷，并杀死了自己的妻子，以便能和奥黛丽在一起。与奥黛丽在一起只是单方面的妄想。
Audrey had nothing to do with the murder or any kind of romance with Dr. Wilkins. She and her mother had actually moved out of the home before this happened, but they were questioned, they had to testify in court, and they were sort of dragged through the mud in the press. The so-called Wilkins case became a phenomenal media scandal, as Audrey told the daily variety in 1920. The Wilkins case ruined my career. I'll never account for anything again. From loving and admiring me, the public seems to have grown to hate me. Audrey couldn't find any work, in film or in artist studios. But the decline of Audrey's career wasn't just because of the Wilkins scandal. She was, after all, totally innocent.
奥黛丽与这起谋杀案或与威尔金斯医生的任何浪漫关系都没有半点关系。在这件事发生之前，她和母亲实际上就已经搬出了那栋房子，但她们受到了讯问，不得不出庭作证，并且在媒体上遭到了一番大肆抹黑。所谓的威尔金斯案成了一场轰动的媒体丑闻，正如奥黛丽在1920年对《每日综艺》所说的那样：“威尔金斯案毁了我的事业。我再也不会有任何成就了。公众从爱戴和崇拜我，似乎变得开始憎恨我了。”奥黛丽找不到任何工作，无论是电影界还是艺术家工作室。但奥黛丽事业的衰落并不仅仅是因为威尔金斯丑闻。毕竟，她是完全无辜的。
There were just a lot of factors changing in the culture around her. For one, the Bowsart style wasn't very popular anymore. The Bowsart style came out of Europe, and there was this thing called World War I where Western Europe kind of fell apart. And so there was a questioning about whether or not we want to be using that kind of symbolism. Both European and American architects were trending towards modernism away from the old world BOSARTS precedents. Also the economics of BOSosedart style were impossible.
只是她周围的文化发生了许多变化。首先，美术派风格不再那么受欢迎了。美术派风格源自欧洲，当时发生了一件叫作第一次世界大战的事情，西欧可以说是支离破碎。因此人们开始质疑我们是否还想使用那种象征意义。无论是欧洲还是美国建筑师，都趋向于现代主义，远离旧世界的美术派先例。此外，美术派风格的经济学成本是不可能的。
It became increasingly expensive to construct these buildings and pay for all of the artists and artisans to design all of the elements of the building and install it. The architectural world didn't need Audrey like it used to, and also, at 30, she was aging out of the business. Audrey's 15-year career as an artist's model had come to an end, and her money started to run out. She moved up state with her mother, who cleaned homes to support them both,
建造这些建筑物并支付所有艺术家和工匠设计建筑的所有元素并进行安装的费用越来越高。建筑界不再像过去那样需要奥黛丽了，而且，在30岁时，她的年龄也超出了这个行业的需求。奥黛丽作为艺术家模特的15年职业生涯走到了尽头，她的积蓄也开始耗尽。她和母亲一起搬到了州北部，她的母亲靠清理房屋来养活两人，
as they tried to carve out a place for themselves in the small rural town of Mexico, New York. It's not an kind of open, easy-going place. Andrea Gyer went up there to talk to people about Audrey. Nobody was unfriendly to me, but there's something about these close-knit communities where as a stranger, you don't feel welcomed. Audrey could not get used to small-town life. Her whole adulthood, she had been traveling around the country, studying art, working with artists,
当她们试图在纽约州小乡村小镇墨西哥镇为自己开辟一席之地时。这不是一个开放、随和的地方。安德烈·盖尔去那里找人聊了聊奥黛丽的情况。没有人对我不友好，但这种紧密的社区有一种特质，作为陌生人，你会觉得不受欢迎。奥黛丽无法习惯小镇生活。她的整个成年时期都在全国各地旅行、研究艺术、与艺术家合作、
engaging in intellectual discussions, and wearing fine clothes. And suddenly she lost it all. Well, she still had the clothes. People told me that she was very flamboyant. She liked to dress up in colorful garments. I mean, I'm sure she had a pretty impressive wardrobe that was very outlandish for a small community, but it wasn't just Audrey's style that set her apart. She would dress up on that and then part of her workout routine in the city was roller skating. So, you know, you can imagine a beautiful
参与知识分子的讨论，穿着华丽的衣服。而转眼间她失去了一切。好吧，她还有那些衣服。人们告诉我她非常浮夸。她喜欢穿五颜六色的衣服。我的意思是，我确信她有一个相当令人印象深刻的衣橱，对于一个小社区来说非常奇特，但不仅仅是奥黛丽的风格使她与众不同。她会盛装打扮，而在城市的日常锻炼中，她的一部分日常是轮滑。所以，你可以想象一个美丽的
woman with long hair and a turban on her head, you know, trying to roll a skate on a country unpaid country road that was quite a scene. The town knew Audrey as that crazy woman who used to get naked for money. Parents would close their windows whenever she came roller skating by. The kids of course were totally fascinated with her, but there was a general consensus that she was crazy just because she was different. So it's not hard to imagine why she would have fallen into a depression. And on May 27th 1922, Audrey Munson attempted suicide by swallowing poison. I don't know how committed her
留着长发、头上戴着头巾的女性，试图在乡村未铺装的乡间小路上玩轮滑，那真是相当奇特的景象。镇上的人都知道奥黛丽是个为了钱而脱得精光的疯女人。每当她轮滑经过时，父母们都会关上窗户。孩子们当然对她着迷不已，但大家的普遍共识是她疯了，仅仅因为她与众不同。所以不难想象她为什么会陷入抑郁。1922年5月27日，奥黛丽·芒森吞服毒药企图自杀。我不知道她的自杀尝试有多坚定。
suicide attempt was. Maybe it was just an expression of being somewhere at the end of her line. After her failed suicide attempt, several maybe it was just an expression of being somewhere at the end of her line. After her failed suicide attempt, several years went by, and Audrey's mother was struggling to provide for her depressed daughter, and she just couldn't do it anymore. On Audrey Munson's 40th birthday, June 8, 1931, her mother checked her into the state mental institution. At that time, it was extremely common for families to put relatives into these institutions
也许这只是她走投无路的一种表达。在她自杀未遂后，几年过去了，奥黛丽的母亲一直在艰难地照顾她情绪低落的女儿，而她实在撑不下去了。在奥黛丽·芒森40岁生日那天，即1931年6月8日，她的母亲将她送进了州立精神病院。在当时，在遭遇财务困难、觉得无法照顾某人时，家属将亲戚送进这些机构是非常普遍的现象。
in moments of financial hardship where they felt they couldn't care for a person. Audrey remained in the institution into her 90s. Then she was put in a nursing home about 30 miles up the road. But this home for the elderly was situated on this little forle in highway. And on the other side of the highway was a little strip mall, which had a bar. And she was known to sneak out of the home for the elderly
奥黛丽在精神病院一直待到90多岁。后来她被送进了一家距离马路大约30英里远的疗养院。但这所老年人疗养院坐落在一条四车道高速公路边的一小块空地上。高速公路的另一边是一个小型的带酒吧的商业街。众所周知，她会偷偷溜出老年疗养院，
and sneak across the forle in highway to spend her evenings at the bar, ordering drinks and telling stories of her times as a model and as an actress. They could not stop this 90-something elegant older woman from running across four lanes of traffic to go to the bar. It's sadly meant that they put her back into the mental institution where she, you know, spent the rest of her life. Audrey Munson lived just short of her 105th birthday. She died in 1996. This public body that once represented truth, civic fame, memory, the universe, and the stars was hidden away for nearly two-thirds of her life. But that one third, that glorious third, immortalized her and placed her all
偷偷穿过四车道高速公路，去酒吧度过她的夜晚，点饮料，讲述她当模特和演员时的故事。人们无法阻止这位90多岁优雅的老年女性跑过四车道车流去酒吧。这不幸地意味着他们把她送回了精神病院，她在那里度过了余下的生命。奥黛丽·芒森去世时距离她105岁生日只差几天。她在1996年去世。这个曾经代表着真理、公民名望、记忆、宇宙和星辰的公共身体，被隐藏了近三分之二的生命。但那三分之一，那辉煌的三分之一，让她不朽，并将她置于全美各地的城市中，高高地栖息着，静静地，隐蔽着，俯视着我们。
over American cities, perched high, quietly, out of sight, staring down at us. I'm wondering if many of my readers have not stood before a masterpiece of lovely sculpture or a remarkable painting of a young girl and asked themselves a question, where is she now? This model who was so beautiful, what has been her reward, is she happy and prosperous, or is she sad and far-lorn, her beauty gone, leaving only memories in the wake? In interview with 99% of his book composer, Sean Rial, right after this. As I mentioned earlier, Miss Manhattan was the first time we worked with our composer, Sean Rial, and during our retreat last weekend, I pulled Sean out of a rousing game of Dixit.
我想知道我的许多读者是否曾站在精美雕塑杰作或年轻女孩卓越画作前，问自己一个问题：她现在在哪里？这个曾经如此美丽的模特，她的回报是什么，她过得快乐而繁荣，还是悲伤而孤独，美貌已逝，只留下回忆在身后？紧接着是对比赛曲作者肖恩·里亚尔的采访。正如我之前所提到的，曼哈顿小姐是我们与作曲家肖恩·里亚尔合作的第一次，在上周末的闭关期间，我把肖恩从一局激烈的《Dixit》（妙笔生花）游戏中拉了出来。
I think that's how you say it, Dixit, I guess, I don't know. Anyway, and asked them how that came about. I was in my car, I was walking dogs as a job, and I caught a text from Avery that just said, would you want to compose music for the show? And I like had to pull over because I was so excited. It felt like a dream come true. Do you remember anything specific about the music
我想是这么读的，Dixit，我猜，我也不知道。不管怎样，我问他是怎么开始合作的。我当时在车里，工作是遛狗，我收到了一条埃弗里的短信，上面只写着：你想不想为这个节目创作音乐？我高兴得不得不把车停在路边。感觉就像梦想成真一样。你还记得关于这期节目的音乐的任何具体内容吗？
from this episode, the Audrey Munson episode, in particular, that you were really proud of? One of the challenges I was having was I really wanted to get the right textures for it because it felt like such a special story, and it felt like it was this architecture that was coming to life, that had life in it, Audrey Munson's personality,
特别是奥黛丽·芒森那一期，你真的很自豪的音乐？我遇到的挑战之一是，我真的很想为它找到合适的质感，因为它感觉像是一个非常特别的故事，而且感觉就像是建筑在苏醒，里面有生命，奥黛丽·芒森的个性，
that was infused in these sculptures. And one of the things that I felt really satisfied about was this one sound I got when I was trying to think like what is like stone and marble and those kinds of things, what kind of texture would feel representative of that. And I have this thing called the Glockenspiel. It's like a little xylophone that's made of metal and it's more like a chimie kind of a sound and usually hit it.
融入了这些雕塑中。让我感到非常满意的事情之一，是我在试图思考石头和大理石以及类似东西是什么样的、什么样的质感能代表它们时，得到了这种声音。我有一个叫作钟琴（Glockenspiel）的东西。就像一个小木琴，是用金属做的，更像是一种叮当声，通常敲击它。
You hear it in a lot of indie folk bands and stuff. So I like to get, and I've like done this before just taking a bow, like a cello bow and just seeing what it does with pretty much anything. And so I, so thinking of the like those kinds of exercises, I took the cello bow and I pulled it on the clock and spiel, and it had a very kind of like coarse texture to it while still like maintaining It's like beautiful tone like it had like a very like specific tone and so I like actually took two bows and I was able to like make harmonies There's one specifically that ends the piece before the credits come up That bit is the screechy, marbly part.
你在很多独立民谣乐队之类的作品中都能听到。所以我喜欢得到，我以前也做过这样的事，只是拿一个琴弓，比如大提琴弓，看看它对几乎任何东西会有什么效果。因此，我思考了诸如此类的练习，我拿着大提琴弓拉了拉钟琴，它有一种非常粗糙的质感，同时又保持着它优美的音色，就像它有一种非常具体的音色一样，所以我实际上拿了两根琴弓，并能够做出和声。有一段专门在演职员表出现之前结束了这段音乐。那一段就是刺耳的、带有大理石质感的部分。
It's like probably one of the most amorphous things I've done for the show. I feel really good just to think that like, oh yeah, that's the Audrey Munson piece. That's like the sound of Audrey Munson. So what is the standard operating procedure for how you work on the show and where you fit into the production cycle? So it starts out with me talking with the producers about the stories that they're working on.
这可能是我为这个节目做过的最无定形的事情之一。一想到“哦，对了，那是奥黛丽·芒森的片段，那是奥黛丽·芒森的声音”，我就觉得感觉非常好。那么，关于你如何参与这个节目以及你在制作周期中扮演什么角色，标准的操作程序是什么？它是从我和制作人们谈论他们正在制作的故事开始的。
They're giving me the personalities of the people they're interviewing and the bigger picture ideas of what they want to convey. And then when there's a first draft, I'm reading it and I'm kind of like writing music as I'm reading it and trying to like get an idea of pacing. But it's really hard to lock that in. And I saw I make sketches basically, but it's hard to lock in like the timing and stuff
他们告诉我他们正在采访的人的个性，以及他们想要传达的更大局的想法。然后当有了初稿时，我在阅读它，边读边写音乐，试图了解节奏。但要锁定这一点真的很难。所以我基本上做的是草稿，但很难锁定时间安排之类的东西，
until we have our read-through edit, where we all sit and we read through the script and play tape. And then I record that, and when I have that, I can actually do my recording and make drafts of my songs to score the piece with. And then from there, we make a rough mix with music, with the music drafts, and everybody gives notes on that. And then from there, I make any changes that we want, and then do the final mixes. When the pieces played out for the first time,
直到我们进行剧本通读编辑，我们所有人坐在一起通读剧本并播放录音带。然后我把它录下来，当我有了这个，我就可以真正开始我的录音，并制作我的音乐草稿来为这个片段配乐。然后从这里，我们用音乐、音乐草稿制作一个粗剪版，每个人都会对此给出意见。然后从这里，我做出我们想要的任何修改，然后进行最后的混音。当音乐第一次播放时，
what is the most common piece of feedback that you get from the producers of the show. The things are too busy. Yeah, it's, I have a very dense sense of rhythm. It's just kind of the way that my head works. I can't do anything simply. And it's really helpful actually to sketch things out with MIDI because I can like just like do a big cluster of notes and then go in and individually pick this one out, pick this one out, pick this one out, and create a rhythm that feels effectively the same but isn't going to be grabbing
你从节目制作人那里得到的最常见的反馈是什么？东西太多了。是的，我的节奏感非常密集。这只是我脑海中运作的方式。我无法把任何事情做得简单。实际上，用 MIDI 画草稿真的很有帮助，因为我可以做一大堆音符，然后进去单独挑出这个，挑出这个，挑出这个，创造出一个感觉上实际上相同但不会当人们在说话并试图解释事情时不断吸引你注意力的节奏。
for your attention constantly when people are talking and trying to explain stuff. One of the funny things about working with musicians for scoring is that some of the most interesting stuff that's going on in the music is in that same zone as the narrator's voice, and you have to kind of scoop that out so that it doesn't compete. I feel like it's like being in a band.
和音乐家合作配乐的一件有趣的事情是，音乐中发生的一些最有趣的事情与旁白的声音处于同一区域，你必须把它挖出来，这样它才不会产生竞争。我觉得这就像在一个乐队里一样。
Like, it's hard to listen to music when everything is like really active and competing. And it's just, I think of it like, whatever's happening in the story right now is the lead instrument. And I'm there to support it. The other instruments aren't less important for not being like the center of attention.
就像，当一切都很活跃且在竞争时，很难去听音乐。而且，我认为这就像是，故事中现在发生的事情是主奏乐器。我是去支持它的。其他乐器并没有因为不是人们关注的中心而变得不那么重要。
It's all working together. So we're going to end this. What would be the composition you'd like to go out on is a proud moment from everything that happened from episode 200 up to now, which is we're getting very close to episode 300. Oh, that's a really wide spectrum. I've written so much music. One that I really, I feel really proud of is the credits music for Man's and R. It feels very sweet in this way that I don't always get to lock into quite the same way.
这一切都在共同作用。所以我们要结束了。你想以什么作为结束的曲目？这是从第200集到现在发生的一切中值得骄傲的时刻，我们正在接近第300集。哦，那是一个非常广泛的范围。我写了太多的音乐。我真正引以为豪的一首是《Man's and R》（曼恩与R）的演职员表音乐。它以一种我并不总能完全以同样方式锁定的方式感觉非常甜蜜。
So I feel special to me. All right, so we're going to go out on Man's Narcredits, performed and composed by Sean Rial, and this is Roman Mars reporting from Dylan Beach at the 99% invisible retreat of 2018 this week by Avery Trouffleman, music by Sean Rial. Katie Mingle is our senior producer Kurt Colstay is the digital director. Delaney Hall is the senior editor. The rest of the team includes Sri Fusif,
所以这对我来说感觉很特别。好吧，所以我们要以肖恩·里亚尔演奏和创作的《Man's and R》演职员表音乐结束，这是罗曼·马尔斯在2018年99% Invisible闭关期间从狄龙海滩发回的报道。本集由埃弗里·特鲁弗曼制作，音乐由肖恩·里亚尔创作。凯蒂·明格（Katie Mingle）是我们的高级制作人，库尔特·科尔斯特（Kurt Kohlstedt）是数字总监。德兰妮·霍尔（Delaney Hall）是高级编辑。团队的其他成员包括斯里·福西夫（Sri Fushif）、
Emmett Fitzgerald, Taren Mazza, and me, Roman Mars. All Audrey Munson quotes, and less otherwise noted, were taken from a tell-all series called Queen of the Artist Studios, that Munson wrote for the New York American in 1921. Audrey Munson was voiced by Cara Rose DeFambio. We are a project of 91.7K ALW in San Francisco and produced on Radio Row in beautiful downtown Oakland, California.
埃梅特·菲茨杰拉德（Emmett Fitzgerald）、塔伦·马扎（Taren Mazza）以及我，罗曼·马尔斯。所有奥黛丽·芒森的引言，除非另有说明，均摘自芒森为1921年《纽约美利坚报》撰写的一系列名为《艺术家工作室的女王》的内幕报道。奥黛丽·芒森由卡拉·罗斯·德法比奥（Cara Rose DeFambio）配音。我们是旧金山 91.7 KALW 的一个项目，在美丽的加州奥克兰市中心的广播街制作。
We are a part of Radio Topia from PRAX, a collective of the best, most innovative shows in all of podcasting. We are supported by our listeners, just like you. You can find the show and join discussions about the show on Facebook. You can tweet at me at Roman Mars in the show at 99PI or work. We're on Instagram, Tumblr, and Reddit too. But we have more visual design stories and videos too at 99PI.org. Radio tapio.
我们是 PRX 旗下 Radiotopia 的一部分，这是一个汇集了所有播客中最优秀、最具创新性节目的集体。我们由像你一样的听众支持。你可以在 Facebook 上找到这个节目并参与关于节目的讨论。你可以在 Twitter 上@我 @Roman Mars，或@节目 @99PI 或 work。我们在 Instagram、Tumblr 和 Reddit 上也有账号。但我们还在 99PI.org 上有更多视觉设计故事和视频。Radiotopia。
From PRX. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
来自 PRX。本集尚无评论。点击文字记录中的任意句子即可留下评论。